the adventures of peter pan have always
been a source of delight for kids who
grew up either reading the stories by
j.m berry or watching the much-loved
animated disney film from 1953.
over the last century there have been
stage plays silent films a slew of
novels and short stories musicals
prequels television specials
and even a walt disney parks and resorts
attraction centered on the antics of the
mischievous young boy who never wants to
grow up
out of all the media featuring peter pan
that's come out in the past 100 years
one stands out as an underappreciated
gem a live action film starring robin
williams that offers a different
perspective on neverland
directed by steven spielberg the 1991
swashbuckling adventure flick hook
follows an adult peter pan now going by
the name peter fanning played by the
late great williams
peter banning is unaware of his former
identity as the boy who flew around
neverland fought pirates and had a tiny
fairy at his beck and call
the adult peter is a career-driven
father of two working long days as a
corporate lawyer in san francisco and
feeling a strain on his marriage because
of it
when the banning family flies to london
to visit moira banning's grandmother
wendy darling
peter's past and present collide as
captain james hook makes a return and
exacts his revenge plot
the evil pirate decides to kidnap
peter's children and it's up to peter to
return to neverland
to save his kids and reconnect with his
inner child by taking a different
approach to the peter pan's story
spielberg managed to tie together themes
of adulthood imagination and childhood
into one heartwarming package
and of course with robin williams's
excellent acting skills his role in hook
really allows the film's message to hit
home
while hook didn't do too well with
critics it's still a classic that
deserves a chance
it seems few people know that more than
netflix subscribers who have been
streaming hooked now more than ever
before
admittedly hook did have its issues and
spielberg himself knew that
the acclaimed filmmaker previously
admitted that he lacked confidence while
making hook and that ended up showing in
the finished product
he told empire magazine i didn't quite
know what i was doing and i tried to
paint over my insecurity with production
value
he also candidly shared that he quote
felt like a fish out of water making
hook
prior to that confession during an
interview with entertainment weekly in
2011
spielberg explained that while there
were parts of the film he enjoyed he's a
little disappointed with how he handled
his leap into neverland
i'm a little less proud of the neverland
sequences because i'm uncomfortable with
that highly stylized world that today of
course i would probably have done with
live action character work inside a
completely digital set
but we didn't have the technology to do
it then and my imagination only went as
far as building physical sets and trying
to paint trees blue and red
unfortunately critics noticed that hook
wasn't exactly perfect
and their largely negative reviews have
placed hook at a 29
approval rating on rotten tomatoes many
critics felt that while the film had
appeal
it lacked depth one review from jonathan
rosenbaum of the chicago reader
criticized hook for its shallow
characters writing
the problems start when we're asked to
accept neverland's two-dimensional
residents as anything other than
tourists on a forced march through its
various nooks and crannies
additionally critics weren't too happy
about the child acting in the film
a review by tim brayton from alternate
ending highlighted this problem stating
given the inherent importance of
children to the peter pan universe it's
damn near fatal that hook has so many
god-awful child roles
you are a very poor role model for these
kids you know that
i bet you don't even have a fourth grade
reading level hemorrhoidal suck navel
although these critiques are valid hook
did seem to go over really well with
audiences scoring a 76 percent amongst
registered users on rotten tomatoes
audience reviews highlight the film's
comedic elements and heartwarming story
and it's clear that overall some viewers
genuinely enjoy spielberg's unique take
on the peter pan narrative
films that were panned by critics but
adored by audiences are fairly common
and it's evident that hook is one of
them
it may not be spielberg's best work but
hook is still worth a watch on netflix
today
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite hidden gems are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one